quite some time ago I was a member of
the vu community and that was a social
network that was very experimental and
what they were what they were all about
was creating two minute or shorter video
responses to two questions and comments
that would come from other V users or
from from the outside and because i had
a web presence already i started getting
a lot of questions about various
different issues some of us I'm about
philosophy in general some about
politics I'm about religion and I'm now
wrapping up with the ones that where I
gave some sort of coherent response I'm
not putting all of them in but some sort
of coherent or interesting response to
questions about about religion and so a
lot of these tend to focus on matters
like arguments for God's existence what
I think about heaven and hell atheism
Satanists thing things like that the
questions would come from all sorts of
quarters so they were a little bit
unpredictable and my answers depended
very much on how i was feeling that day
and what i wanted to to say so here are
10 more and these are the last of the
religion oriented videos 10 more very
short clips answering questions about
religion
well this is this is a good question if
you don't send does this mean Jesus died
for nothing now if you mean you as in
Greg Sadler me it's not an issue because
I sinned and I send plenty and I'll bet
you that all be you know doing some
things wrong till till I die hopefully
they're going to be pretty minor things
but you know I know myself well enough
to think that there's never any
possibility that i'm not going to be
doing something wrong does this mean
Jesus died for nothing let's say we take
a hypothetical in there and you've got
some some singles person who would be
asking this question that means they
they never sinned right they not only
haven't committed sins they're not
committing sins they won't be committing
sins what's let's assume that that that
leap is possible all right does that
mean Jesus died for nothing ah no
because right there's six billion other
people in the world so and all these
other people you know in the past and
all these other people coming in the
future it's not as if Jesus only died
for one person and that's it if you
happen to be so good that you never
sinned well then I guess he didn't die
for you right but he certainly did for
me and for for everybody else and so
we'll take it if it doesn't if you don't
need it we'll use it right so yeah
there's the answer it's kind of a good
question though because you know it sets
up a really interesting hypothetical
possibility let's say let's say Adam
Adam and Eve had never sinned you know
how would things have gone then there
wouldn't have been any need for for
redemption maybe they would have been
confirmed in their justice the way the
Angels who didn't follower I'd be an
interesting possibility it's discussed
by some theologians and I don't really
remember the discussions because I
didn't pay very close attention to them
okay so you've asked me to really big
involved questions and I'm not a
theologian I'm a philosopher whose work
sometimes goes into theology and who as
a Catholic philosopher it was work is
informed to some degree by the broad
theological tradition I'll answer the
first question and if you want to ask me
the second question is a separate
question I can do that but we only get a
certain amount of time so I'm going to
read you something actually from the
life of st. handsome which is really
startling so an some would say that if
he should see before his very eyes the
horror of sin on the one hand the pains
of hell on the other was obliged to
plunge into one of the other he would
choose help rather than sin and he was
in the habit of saying something else
which perhaps appeared to some people no
less remarkable that he would prefer to
be free from sin and go to hell
innocently then go to the kingdom of
heaven polluted with the stain of sin
since this saying seems strange to some
people he explained and softened it
saying it's certain that only the wicked
are tormented in hell and only the good
are happy in the kingdom of heaven
therefore it's clear that the good if
they could enter hell could not be
visited with punishment due to the
punishment due to the wicked nor could
the evil if they could get to heaven
enjoy their the blessedness of the good
and that's a really interesting way of
thinking about things I mean it's very
augustinian this idea that heaven and
hell are not sort of external places
that you get thrown into but rather have
to do with the state of the person and
actually you find that in Plato to you
find that in in quite a few philosophers
even before the Christian era so
those are just a few of my spot doesn't
happen to know I mean he asked me a big
question that I can't answer and in just
a few short moments but I think that's a
good story though and I think it does
illustrate an interesting point
well let me say first that I really like
the idea of atheists finding themselves
in a place that they then claim well I
don't believe in this well you know when
you get there buddy tough [ __ ] right
you're stuck so if the theists are right
and and their conception of the good
place to bad place whether it's a final
resting place or not because there are
some you know metaphysical schemes in
which there are different layers and all
sorts of complexities to it but if
they're right that there is a final
judgment and atheist wind up going one
way or the other I kind of get a kick
out of the idea of them saying oh but I
don't believe in this well doesn't
matter what you believe sometimes it
matters what is and the key is to align
your beliefs with what is now the
theological question of atheists going
to heaven or hell it's not something
that you can answer carte blanche I
think although I think a lot of people
would say that automatically atheists
are going to go to help here's my view
and it's derived from the fact that I'm
a Catholic philosopher and and there's a
lot of discussion of this in Catholic
and Eastern Orthodox thought is it
possible that an atheist could go to
heaven through God's mercy because they
are not you know choosing their atheism
per se like consider somebody brought up
in a communist country where the church
had been effectively wiped out or where
the church had given so much scandal
that that it was very difficult to
believe could that person go to heaven I
don't see why not I mean if God chooses
to extend his mercy in that way that
doesn't seem unreasonable to me at all
will somebody who's willfully choosing
atheism go to hell I think likely
although I also think that a lot of
people who
who are practicing religion are likely
to go to hell too but I'm very concerned
that I don't go there so
well do I believe in luck good or bad
yes I'm not sure it says I've asked many
religious here and I still can't believe
their answers so I'm guessing that
you're not you're not happy with the
answer is that they gave you might not
be happy with the answer that I gave do
I believe in anything like pure chance
no I believe that luck is where
different things come together and like
Aristotle says the that which is done by
chance is actually where there's a lot
of different causes coming together that
we don't fully understand so I don't see
luck as actually something that is
totally incompatible with the the notion
which is something else that I also hold
that that everything is also part of one
big massive comprehensive very flexible
providential ordering of things so
flexible that it can even take into
account human free will and the effects
of human free will on further free
willing I believe that that's actually
part of the providential ordering so
yeah I do believe in something like luck
and I don't actually place a great
premium on it I think when I was when I
was younger I was much more interested
in luck now I I think about what do I
need to do in the situation how do I
prepare for things and yeah this is
something I need to think more about
though so I don't actually have at this
point I'm sort of running out of answers
which is kind of interesting so I want
to cut it short here
okay so this looks to me like a question
that would be good for dr. Sadler's
chalk and talk because it deserves much
longer than than two minutes I'll give
you a very short answer to this and then
i'll tell you kind of a funny story so
short answer why does God want people to
believe in him and then give such
minimal evidence to his existence it
really depends on what you count as
evidence there's many different modes of
evidence if you mean something that's
sort of like publicly accessible in
convincing with no interpretation
required to everybody then yeah you're
right not a lot of evidence in that
sense but is that what we actually mean
by evidence and we're talking about
personal beings or about you know say
the border of Providence or things like
along those lines well then we get into
all different modes of evidence and that
that's a complicated issue so I'm going
to defer that so here's the funny story
when I was in high school and this is a
catholic high school I took a philosophy
class and I you know as in most of my
classes I screwed off a lot and didn't
apply myself but but I was smart so I
could I could kind of get away with it
and on one of the tests one of the
things we've been talking about is this
you know arguments for God's existence
of evidence and all that and I'm a test
we had an essay question and it ran
something like if you were God would you
have made your existence easier
difficult to prove and so I wrote I
would have made it very very difficult
to prove and I would have killed anybody
with a lightning bolt who came close to
discovering the proof why because that
would keep the whole process going for
for all eternity you know it's a sort of
typical thing a smartass teenager says I
got an F on that test because that is
not the right answer
so you've watched some of my videos
regarding my faith I'm guessing it must
just be vu stuff because I haven't
really done anything on YouTube with
that and you're wondering whether I've
read The God Delusion no I haven't read
it just read losses on it but you know
from glosses it's not really doing
anything radically new and these
questions have been discussed for a very
long time from a you know a lot of
different perspectives by very smart
people I don't think that it that it
adds anything new to the discussion just
keeps it going on that's fine how do I
specifically refute the claims I don't I
leave that up to other people i have so
many other projects going on right now
that I don't worry about Dawkins and and
his stuff you know I've got my my
classes to run my personally my faith
life doesn't depend anything on what
Richard Dawkins thinks and I'm not
bothered in the least nor I think most
believers by the fact that some other
people don't believe are very vehemently
opposed to belief and bring out all
sorts of arguments against
it's a question of whether you find
those arguments convincing or not so I
would much rather read great
philosophers if I want to have an
atheist interlocutor I'd much rather
read a great philosopher or just read
stuff you know like Dostoyevsky's
characters some of them were atheists it
makes amazing variance against God I'd
much rather engage that sort of stuff I
find them more fruitful so
what do I say to the various invisible
gardener arguments that get started by
by Jon wisdom who by the way I very much
liked as a philosopher I don't say
anything to them because I haven't
really looked at them for a few years
and I never found them particularly
interesting anyway I've never really
found from a philosophical perspective
all these debates that took place in
anglo-american philosophy about
verification and you know whether it
consisted in falsifiability or you know
all this sort of stuff I never found
that very interesting it didn't tell me
anything about what I wanted to know
about in philosophy of religion and
really what counts as verification it
ends up being such an easily shifting
boundary line not only for the theists
who can always you know say oh well I
didn't mean that I didn't mean that I
didn't mean that but also for the the
other side the agnostic sore skeptics or
atheists who can say oh that doesn't
count that doesn't count that doesn't
count I've never been very interested
myself in this idea of having to prove
God's existence to the non-believer I'm
always much more interested in you know
with retirement philosophy of religion
in conceptions of God and so I you know
less in existence and more in the divine
attributes and interactions with
creation and then you know what would
that mean concretely i'm interested in
religious experience as well and if you
start bringing in these these
verification estar gyea ments to
religious experience well it all just
disappears but that seems to me just
silly there's something there we don't
want to just dismiss it all out of hand
and so you know invisible Gardner I
don't really do much with it I think
that the time for that is kind of past
well quite simply I don't think God does
care more about America than he does any
third world country I mean I could be
wrong on that I don't know the mind of
God but I don't see any any evidence
that God cares more about us in the
sense of caring more for us than he does
third world countries I think he might
care more about us in that he thinks
we'd be more culpable because we have a
lot more opportunities to do the right
thing and any anybody who wants access
to learning about the right thing has
innumerable opportunities to do so in
this country I mean we have open access
to all sorts of knowledge whether
through the internet through libraries
through people willing to reach out to
you so if anybody wants to know what
what reason dictates our conscience
dictates or you know about religious
teachings or anything like that they
wanted to really grasp what God is
asking them to do what God's will is
they they can you know they can figure
it out if they want to I don't think
most people want to or they would very
much like it to be what what they would
like it to be wouldn't they yeah and I
and I'm not saying that I'm above that
myself because I find myself often
questioning what I made of things but
now here's the interesting thing a lot
of people do think that that God cares
more about America that were somehow
special that's called American
exceptionalism and it goes all the way
back to some of our cultural foundings
in the the pilgrims and some other
Protestant denominations that come over
John Winthrop he's got this trope of a
city on a hill you know which is which
is coming from the Bible and the notion
is America or at least you know the
fledgling colony is a city on the hill
well that means not only you're a model
but that means that you better get it
right or you're going to get in trouble
just like Israel in the Bible over and
over again they get it wrong and then
that's mad
okay my feelings on Satanism I don't
think you can actually say they even
rise to the level of feelings it's not
something I've actually thought about
for quite a while you know I used to
teach Religious Studies classes for ball
state college at Indiana State Prison
and we'd talk about it there towards the
end of the semester and religion in
American culture is one of the
alternative religious movements along
with you know some other things along
those lines I can tell you that when I
was a kid growing up in the 80s wearing
a leather jacket you know and having
longer hair than this and listening to a
lot of heavy metal music we had people
who thought her sickness and when I
brought home Ronnie James Dio is holy
diver album my mom was very concerned
you know because it shows this big
satanic figure throwing a priest into a
pool um I gotta say you know I've dealt
with some students who at least claim to
be Satanists oh no I believe were
actually quite hard core about it and
I've had some associates in other places
I find them kind of tame I think the
devil is a much more interesting figure
in Jewish Christian Islamic Ginoza
astron literature than he is in the
literature the Satanist unfortunately
there's something about turning in the
or get into an object of worship that
how it kind of trivializes this stuff
and you know
there's there's a show I like called met
apocalypse and they have this band
dethklok they're very metal and they
decide they're going to become Satanist
they become very disappointed when they
join the church and they find out it's
actually quite tame they have to
actually been my experience with a lot
of Satanists and I think Satanism kind
of tends towards that you know there's
there's
well i was actually near the end of what
i was saying when I got slightly cut off
I what I didn't have much more to add to
it but your question opens up some new
things that I could talk about that's
there's a side note if you keep on
asking me questions I can go on for
hours and hours talking about all sorts
of things because my head is is kind of
crammed full like a dusty attic full of
gets a trivia about things are things
I've thought about in the past and then
they come to light so what about the
idea of not denying earthly pleasure and
urges yeah actually I'm quite in favor
of earthly pleasure and urges within
certain limits and any rational being
can't totally indulge themselves in any
particular urge or flee pleasure else
you know leads to catastrophic effect I
mean feels good to sleep but you can't
sleep all day long and it feels good to
have sex but you can't do that all day
long and you can't drink all the time or
you know eat all the time you can try as
a matter of fact back when I was in
graduate school I did an experiment with
a friend of mine we decided we are going
to just drink for an entire week and
that's all we were going to do we made
it to that day five we felt so terrible
that we had to discontinue the
experiment and actually you know it's
interesting a lot of people think that
religion is about denying earthly
pleasure and urges properly understood
if you look at any of the great world
religious traditions well I have to
qualify Jainism okay if you actually
read the texts big-time asceticism but
most of them don't actually devalue
pleasure
and urges they just place it within a
larger context so